bei mir im studio ist eine junge dame
die hat absolut da keine probleme sie
hat 2,4 millionen instagram follower das
muss man sich wirklich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen herzlich willkommen
katja krasser witze richtig hallo hallo
hallo schön schön bestimmt dass du da
bist
wir hatten hier zum teil immer mal
wieder das thema influenza du bist ja
wahrscheinlich da bombastisch
aufgeschüttet was wir erzählt du hast du
wahnsinnig vollen terminkalendern wie
geht's in influenza jetzt so in dieser
kroner zeit gibt weniger termine ja
kommt darauf an was für den fenster mann
ist gibt verschiedene arten und weisen
das ist so riesig also bei mir sicher so
ich mache verschiedenes achten wie
youtube tik tok
ich mache aber auch musik aber ich bin
auch live auf der tour gewesen und wenn
es jetzt um tour geht was halt schlecht
mit corona aber wenn es um in frieden zu
erleben geht da kann man sehr viel
machen und man kann sehr viele apps
bedienen man kann sehr viele bewerbungen
machen man kann eigentlich verschiedene
dinge machen das internet läuft immer
internet läuft immer wie ist das so mit
dem finanziellen ist das jetzt
eingeschränkt viele sagen ja mit ich
habe jetzt gar keine
es gibt keine kampagnen zum beispiel wie
super dir zum glück lebe ich ja nicht
von kampagnen ich lebe er von meinen
fans und ich habe zum beispiel ein buch
herausgebracht solche sachen kann man
immer machen weil online verhandelt oder
beziehungsweise verschickt alles und
online live gehen verschiedene apps neu
machen ich habe mir tik tok gemacht hat
jetzt 1,1 millionen followern der korona
zu machen
ich glaube dass die leute jetzt mehr im
internet sind und dass für die in
fernseher natürlich gut ist du sprichst
ja vorwiegend junge junge frauen an
mit mit kosmetik mit mit beauty da gibt
es ja wahrscheinlich auch viele mädchen
die sagen ich möchte so werden wie du
ich bin totaler fan von dir
ich mache jetzt auch auf influenza
kannst du das den jungen mädchen
empfehlen
es ist ein sehr harter weg kommt
natürlich drauf an was für ein mensch
man ist also jetzt auf meine art und
weise wie ich es gemacht habe ich bin ja
sehr gemobbt wurden weil ich halt eben
so toll dort operiert werden so
freizügig heute man nicht so freizügig
freizügig rumlaufen
kommt drauf an was man machen möchte
aber wenn man in die öffentlichkeit
gehen will ist es sehr schwierig als man
muss auf jeden fall sehr stark sein und
damit rechnen dass auch hält geben wird
man muss einfach durch das alles
durchgehen es ist nicht einfach so ok
ich fange jetzt einfach so nach oben
sondern es geht einfach so so so so und
dann kommt wieder in die krise und dann
läuft's nicht und blablabla also es ist
sehr viel arbeit für den kopf